[MUSIC PLAYING]
MILES WARD: Hi, everybody.
My name's Miles Ward.
I run the solutions
architecture practice
for Google Cloud worldwide.
And I have to tell you, I have
been working with the team
at Twitter now for two years,
and I cannot be more proud
to be on stage to show you and
help you see what it is that
they are doing
with our platform.
They have prepared
a presentation
to really unfold how it is that
they are adopting Google Cloud.
And I'm just incredibly
excited about this moment.
So to really take
you through it,
I want to introduce Derek Lyon,
who runs VP of Engineering
here at Twitter.
Thank you so much.
DEREK LYON: So I'm going to talk
a little bit about our journey
to the cloud.
We actually didn't
know initially
that we were going to do Hadoop.
That was something we
discovered during the process.
So I'm going to start
out talking a little bit
about our infrastructure
in general,
and how we did the
evaluation here.
So first of all,
Twitter's infrastructure,
we were founded in 2006.
That may seem familiar.
That's the year that some of the
first cloud services started.
We were actually
slightly before them.
So cloud was not a
choice that anybody
was making at that time.
Over time we've grown up to be a
global scale application, which
is quite large.
There are other larger
applications out there,
but not very many, actually.
Twitter, relative to
other large web sites,
has some very unique performance
and scale considerations.
Especially, we do a
lot of real-time stuff.
As you'll see, our data platform
is pretty large as well.
And over time, over
the last 12 years,
we've grown our footprint
in our data centers.
And a lot of it's
built to purpose.
We have enough
scale that we're not
buying hardware off the racks.
We're buying stuff that
is built specifically
for the workload that's running.
So it's relatively
efficient, which
I think makes cloud
adoption a little bit more
challenging for us
as a decision than it
would be if you were
a start-up buying
stuff from a retail website.
So the strategic
questions that we set out
to answer-- first of all, what's
the long-term mix of cloud
in our portfolio.
We're big enough
that we can afford
to do stuff relatively cost
effectively in the data center.
At the same time, doing
zero things on the cloud
seems probably not enough.
But there's a pretty wide range
of opinions within Twitter
around what exactly
that ratio was.
Second question is which
cloud vendor should we use?
And obviously the choice is, I
think, well anticipated here.
But a really
important one for us
organizationally is
also how do we become
confident in this decision.
So there's a range
of opinions inside
of Twitter around what works
well, what doesn't work well.
People have had
different experiences
at different companies.
How do we actually
collect real data
and make a real
engineering decision
about what we're
going to do in a way
that we can defend and
organize people around.
And then we started
this evaluation in 2016.
So Miles mentioned, it's
been about two years.
We'll share some numbers.
Some of those are perhaps a
little bit dated right now.
So as you listen
to the talk, I'd
encourage you to think about the
process as much as the results.
And your mileage
will, of course, vary,
and some of the providers
have improved since then.
So the more tactical questions
that we're trying to answer--
and I don't want
to minimize these
by calling these tactical.
Some of these are actually
the hardest and most important
questions.
Number one is how
feasible is it to move
either Twitter or some
large portion of Twitter
to the cloud.
What's the cost of that?
How do you identify
the workloads
that you can actually
separate if you're
going to do a hybrid cloud model
using pretty mature software
that hasn't anticipated the
hybrid cloud model previously?
Do you re-architect
things as you do that?
Or do you do a lift-and-shift?
And then how do you
put all this together
into an actionable plan,
with a budget and a timeline
and everything else?
It's a massive problem.
So 2016, our process maybe is a
little bit different than some
people's.
So if you're somebody who
has a renewal on the data
center coming up, and you need
to make a decision quickly,
this may not be exactly
the right process for you.
We had the opportunity
to make a patient
and a rigorous decision.
And at our scale small
errors in calculations
are large numbers in
an absolute sense.
So you'll see that we try to be
very detailed in our decision
making.
So we knew that we
wanted to look at this.
We started out deciding
that we wanted to analyze
this on a workload basis.
So we started out defining
the baseline requirements
for each of our workloads.
We actually sent RFPs out to
all the different providers
that we thought might
be candidates for us.
And then, in each
case, we analyzed
how each workload would
run on each provider,
and then built a
plan, and aggregated.
Here's a little bit
of the timeline.
I'll kind of walk through this.
You can see a lot of the
core engineering work
that we'll talk about in the
evaluation process was here
in fall of 2016.
And then there's quite
a bit of iteration
and organizational approvals,
and other sorts of things.
And then where we are now,
we actually just started
our migration process.
So April was kind of the
official deal assigned.
We're doing it.
And June is effectively when
we had everybody in seats,
and really kind of
working on this.
So it's pretty new.
Yeah.
So the different workloads
that we looked at,
this looks probably
pretty comprehensive.
It was intended to be
We looked at real-time systems.
We looked at NoSQL systems.
We looked at messaging, object
store database, general purpose
computing, and batch computing.
And each one of these, we'll
talk about the evaluation
process for Hadoop,
because that's
the one that we
found interesting,
and that's the one
where we're actually
going to change what we're doing
as a result of what we found.
But we did a similar analysis
for each one of these,
actually.
So for each of these
workloads, what we looked at
was kind of two
high-level options.
Do we just use--
the provider is doing
something better than we are.
We should just use what
they're doing, and game over.
Or should we run our
own service there?
And if we do run it there,
do we just lift and shift
what we're doing today, or do
we re-architect in some way,
because the provider
has some primitives that
perform differently, or offer
different functionality that's
interesting to us?
The interesting note
here at the bottom--
and this is something I'd
encourage you to think about--
not every user of that platform
will take the same approach.
So a very small-scale
database might
benefit from just using
provider-managed service.
If it happens to be the
Twitter graph or something,
it may be a little harder to run
that on the provider service.
So you may choose to
segment a little bit,
depending on the scale
complexity and uniqueness
of the workload.
So for the evaluation, this
is kind of a generic process.
This I would, if you're
going to take a photo,
this is probably a good one.
So we started out with
functional testing
to just make sure that all
of our software would run.
We did find a few
minor bugs there.
That was a little bit
less interesting, though.
The core of the
process though was
doing microbenchmarking for each
resource that we depended on.
And we used that to then
figure out what the candidate
configurations would be.
So which class of storage gives
the performance characteristics
that we want for this
type of workload.
Once we had a couple of
candidate configurations
for each workload, we then
moved on to macrobenchmarking,
where we actually ran
large-scale application
benchmarks to actually
see how the workload would
perform in a realistic way.
We tried to do
some scale testing.
In some cases we couldn't
go to full Twitter scale,
but we tried to go within
an order of magnitude
if we could, as close
to reality as we could.
That's actually one that
a lot of people don't do,
because it costs a
little bit of money.
But I would encourage
you to do that.
We did find stuff there.
We'll talk about that later.
And then this was kind of
a cool thing that we did.
Each time we found
something, we showed it
back to the provider with the
scripts that we were using,
and everything
else, and asked them
to validate that the
numbers we were seeing
are what they expected.
And then, you know, we continued
to iterate on this process.
So the kind of core first
run through that process
was about 2 and 1/2 months to
do this on multiple providers.
So it actually didn't
take that long.
I would encourage
you to do that.
The next-- well
over a year, here--
was us trying to get to
a very precise answer.
So if you're looking
for an 80/20 solution,
the two or three
month approach is
pretty reasonable for
any 80/20 solution.
If you need higher
accuracy than that,
expect to run through this
process a couple of times.
So coming out of that, we
built an overall cloud plan
that we wanted to then assess.
This included
candidate architectures
for each of these workloads that
was driven by the benchmarking
that we'd done before.
From there, we tried
to work backwards
into what the migration plan
would look like for each
of those workloads,
the dependencies
between the workloads on
each other, and the timeline.
And then we created some
financial projections
associated with that, which I'll
talk about in just a second.
And then there's some other
business considerations
as well.
So the financial
modeling, this we
did a pretty elaborate
version of this.
I'm very grateful to our finance
team for their support in this.
We looked at a 10-year horizon.
That seems ridiculously
long, but that's actually
the asset lifetime of
a lot of the assets
that you're comparing against--
like a data center,
that's a typical duration.
And we did find that if you
look at something shorter term,
you're very sensitive
to how recently you just
bought servers, or when
your lease is coming up.
So it was important to
do a long enough time
horizon that we weren't subject
to those timing effects.
We looked at multiple
different cloud scenarios.
We also looked at our
on-premises scenario.
And in the on-premises
case, we also
made sure to layer
in improvements
that we knew we could do.
So if there's a tech refresh
that's going to help us there,
we layered all that in.
The costs actually
kind of interestingly
segmented out into
immigration period cost,
where you're running
duplicate infrastructure,
and you're very sensitive to
the time of the migration plan,
and if you can cut things over
at exactly the right time.
And it's actually quite
constrained and complicated.
And then the longer term
was kind of past the point
where we had immediate
visibility into what exactly
was going to happen.
So there there's
long term curves,
like Moore's law for the CPU.
We looked at full
historical pricing
for how providers have been
cutting costs and stuff,
and then tried to layer that
into the long-term projection
to get a sense
for how costs were
evolving on a relative basis.
And then this one
adds a lot of work.
But it was important for
us, because the numbers
were so big.
We actually maintain
two independent models
with separate
calculation paths, so
that if somebody makes
an error, we can actually
see the model error there,
because the two models wouldn't
converge in that case.
And getting those to converge
was a fair bit of work.
So what we found, this was
kind of the key takeaway,
and then we'll go through
the process that got us here.
An immediate all-in migration
at Twitter scale was expensive.
We found it would be more
expensive, especially if we
didn't optimize as we went.
It was going to
block a ton of teams
for a long period of time, and
distract us from other stuff
that we thought we needed
to work on as a business.
And there was a lot of
risk associated with that.
So if we got halfway
through that migration,
and something was
going sideways,
that was a pretty big problem.
What we did discover
coming out of that
is that in cases where we can
embrace a new architecture
or transform something
and really take
advantage of
something that cloud
is providing that we
don't already have,
there may be more value there.
And so we decided to pick
something smaller that we
actually could do a meaningful
transformation with,
learn from that.
And then I'm sure our strategy
will evolve over time.
Hadoop was the workload that
we picked, because we actually
found some very
interesting things there.
And we'll do a re-architecture
as part of the migration.
And one cool outcome
out of this, actually--
so there's a range of
opinions about what
the strategy should be.
I think it's actually
clarified a lot for us.
We know what we're moving.
And we're able to
now fully invest
in moving that, and doing
a good job with that.
We also know we're not
moving any time soon.
And we're able to invest more in
running that in the data center
as well.
So it's no longer this
debate about should we
really invest in that?
Is that going to
disappear in two years?
No, it's not going to
disappear in two years.
It's safe to invest in that.
And I think as a
result we're actually
doing a better job
in both environments
than we had previously.
So with that, I'm going
to hand off to Dave.
And he's going to talk
a little bit about what
we looked at for Hadoop.
DAVID BECKETT: Hi, everyone.
I'm Dave.
I'm a staff site reliability
engineer on the data
infrastructure side.
So I'm going to talk to
you about the details.
And first of all, I'm not
sure if everyone knows Hadoop.
So I'll try to cover it in
as few slides as possible.
It's a file system
which is called HDFS.
It lets you run
distributed applications
with an API in runtime
that's called YARN.
And then we have a data
processing framework
or multiple frameworks.
MapReduce is one everyone
has probably heard of.
And there's a lot more to it.
In general, though,
Hadoop's principles
are this-- it's a
distributed system.
So it's built from lots of nodes
or computers operating as one.
It is horizontally scalable.
If you want to increase your
capacity in compute or storage,
you just add more nodes.
It's a large scale.
We care about terabytes
and petabytes or larger.
And we carry up to ten
of thousands of nodes.
That's a typical
scale for Hadoop.
Hadoop itself is fault
tolerant and self-healing,
so it handles failure
of machines and hardware
and software systems.
And it runs on
commodity hardware.
So that's just Hadoop
out of the box.
But Hadoop is strategically
important for Twitter itself.
We use it for a large variety
of compute in the company.
For example, on
the data side, we
use it to store core data,
the systems, and objects
such as tweets.
We all have all our
company logs in there.
We also use it for backups and
other durable storage cases.
On the analytics side, where
we're looking into data,
we do all our
metrics work there,
and all our aggregates--
accounting, sorting, grouping,
all that kind of stuff
at large scale, which is
what we're talking about here.
And then we have
the insight side,
which is where we do
things like machine
learning model training
over vast data sets,
where we do experiments--
that is, both
create the experiments
in a computing sense,
and analyze results
that we have gathered
from other experiments.
And we also do this
ad hoc computing,
or analysis in there.
So if somebody has
a brilliant idea,
they write an algorithm,
or piece of code,
and they want to run it.
Generally it's a
human doing this.
Rather than something
super-automated,
it's usually one-off
or irregularly needed.
So talking about Hadoop
scale, what do we have?
We run over a half a million
compute cores in Twitter.
We have over 300 petabytes of
logical storage in production.
And our Hadoop
cluster side, we have
clusters that have gone
up to 12,500 nodes, which
is some of the larger
Hadoop clusters
that we know of publicly.
In terms of the sort of
rate of change of things,
this is just messages that
are going into Hadoop.
It doesn't include other things
that the company's doing.
And we have over a
trillion messages a day
going into our Hadoop clusters.
There is actually an Apache
conference talk about that,
if you want to Google that.
But the workload that
we have is broken up.
And here's the kind of the
way that we think about it--
the cluster types.
Going from the top down, we
have our real-time clusters.
These are used for very
high-performance critical event
processing.
Its about 10% of our compute.
We have our regular scheduled
processing production jobs.
That's core-based compute load.
That's about 60% of it.
In the green, we have our
ad-hoc, or one-off queries
and analysis stuff.
That's the stuff
that's very spiky--
about 30%.
And then we have
our cold clusters,
which are mostly storage.
We would have very minimal
compute going on in there.
And this will come
up in a second.
So we have challenges based
on all this kind of things
that we want to do as a company.
We have the challenge of scale.
We have significant year-on-year
computing and storage growth
in the double digits.
We have hardware to operate.
We have to design and build
and maintain and operate it.
We have a capacity planning.
It's especially hard
for us to predict
the growth of the compute
in the ad hoc case.
And we have agility,
and that is responding
fast to customer requests
when an internal team wants
us to do something to actually
add storage or compute.
This is especially
tricky as well,
also, for the ad hoc case.
Deployment-- we have to
get this all running.
We have to keep it running.
It has to be able to
work at scale in the tens
of thousands size of clusters.
And it also has to be able
to be upgraded in flight.
We don't turn these things off.
The network, as you can
imagine, we have a lot of data.
We move it around
between data centers,
as well as inside the clusters.
And we also have to think
about disaster recovery.
We keep a lot of data.
We want to make
sure it's durable,
and we have the ability to
survive individual failures.
So in general, we have
this kind of requirement.
And I want you to think
about the top two, really.
We care about network.
Sustained bandwidth
we can get per core.
We care about the sort of
bulk part of the network.
We care about
sustained bandwidth
per core on disk side.
Again, it's bulk.
We care about large
sequential reads and writes.
Throughput, not latency.
And we also care about capacity.
We do have to store
a lot of data.
So CPU and RAM are not
really our big concerns.
They're down the list
of things we worry
about in terms of hardware.
And we also care about the
consistency of data sets,
because we are moving
around lots of files,
and we consider a set of
files to be a dataset.
And we want it to
arrive or to be
generated in one consistent
way, so you can actually
operate on it.
And here's an example of
the kind of on-premise SKU
that we have, just a very sketch
of the sort of capacity things
that we got there.
So they're a reasonably
modest kind of hardware.
We all have clusters in the
range of 10 to 20,000 nodes.
We're moving to 25G network.
And you can see from our
network numbers at the bottom
that there's some
particular numbers.
But notice the peaks.
We go from a peak, or we go
from average to peak up to 10x.
And that's not 8, and
that's not unusual.
So we have lots of loads
that vary quite a lot.
So going back to the cloud
architectural options
that we had when we were
looking during the evaluations,
we could use the
Hadoop as a service
that the cloud
providers gave you.
And we could also do our own
Twitter Hadoop on cloud VMs.
For that, on the
choice number two,
we have two storage options--
two storage parts--
the durable storage,
which we were not going
to ever do anything
but put it on the
cloud object store;
and on the scratch storage.
So Hadoop needs temporary
files, intermediate files
that are used for calculations
during the MapReduce steps.
We have choices there.
With HDFS over the object store,
HDFS over the block store.
So that's like a file
system approach--
the next file system.
And then we can use
HDFS on local disks,
the local attached
disks of the nodes.
So this is the plan
that we work through.
We have our baseline test
that Derek was telling you,
just sort of to establish what
is the sort of configuration
that we would want to work on.
And these are all standard
Hadoop distribution tests
out of the box, you can get
that measure various low-level
read and write things.
And things like Terasort
is a MapReduce application
that reads a lot of data,
then short shuffles,
and moves it around
the network, moves it
from disk into memory and back.
And then it writes it all.
But it's very lockstep.
It's very uniform It
doesn't really generate a--
it's a repeatable thing,
but it doesn't give you
something that actually
matches what your production
workload is.
So looking to the right, we're
emphasizing the functional
test.
This is Gridmix.
Gridmix again is a
standard part of Hadoop.
When we used a capture of a
real production workload--
so we grabbed what happened when
1,000 jobs were running on one
of our clusters-- one of
our production clusters--
then we could replay it--
the reads and writes and
the way that the job worked
and computed.
So we actually get a pattern
that's not so lockstep.
It actually matches
our production load
with overlapping jobs, and
some slightly slower or longer
that actually stresses the
system more realistically.
So the HDFS
configurations we tested,
we were looking for
these kind of things
in all of the storage solutions
that we were looking for.
So we wanted availability in two
regions for our critical data,
and two zones for other--
for intermediate data
and other data.
The data set consistency.
So this is where we
have a set of files
that we want to manipulate.
Let's say 1,000
files form a dataset,
because even some of our
bigger pieces of data
are just too big to
manipulate in files.
I mean, our block size
in Hadoop is 512 meg.
What we typically have
files that are gigabytes.
And we have thousands of
those to form a data set.
So to get a consistent view
of that, cloud providers,
either you can use
the object store.
And then you can
use the object store
with some external
consistency service.
Those were the two
choices we had.
So I want to go into the Hadoop
evaluation now in more depth.
There were two choices
for us on Google Cloud.
We could use Cloud
Dataproc, which
is the Hadoop as a service.
And we could use Compute Engine
with Twitter Hadoop's stack
on top.
We decided to start
for the evaluation
with Dataproc, because it
could be deployed right away.
It was instantly available.
And we didn't need to
port any systems in order
to get it running.
Its version was similar enough
to our on-premise Hadoop
that we were OK with it in
terms of matching what we were
going to be actually using.
So this is for the evaluation.
And here is our
actual configuration
that we use for our
Dataproc testing.
So we worked with 800 VC
views and two different SKUs
and one standard 8 and
4, but always the 800
VCPUs to match what we
were capturing on-premise.
And we did a scale
test with 8,000 VCPUs
as well, just to see what
we could do as a peak.
We modeled average CPU,
and average to peak.
We turned off or didn't use
any preemptible instances,
because we wanted
something repeatable.
We wanted the people to be able
to trust the numbers we had.
And we chose SKUs,
which you can see
will roughly match
our on-premise SKUs.
So we were reasonably
comparing like-to-like.
So I'm not going to
read out these slides.
But if you want to know
how to do this yourself,
you can go through the
slide deck and have a look.
How to get the Rumen--
I don't know how you
pronounce that-- the way
that you can do the
trace capturing stuff.
There is the command
line we ran to do that.
You can then use
the Gridmix replay
command, which is written
there in the Gridmix bundle.
So I'm not going
to read those out.
But that's what we used.
And here's the results.
So first, n1-standard-8, if you
look at the right-hand column,
we're comparing the
speed-up that we
tested in our evaluation
to on-premise.
So the first line is using SSDs,
which we find was 2x faster,
but it's expensive.
You're paying for SSDs.
The other two ones
are using PD-HDD.
So, hard drive over PD--
Persistent Disk.
And we changed the
Compute Engine types
to get the balance of
network cores and storage
that we needed.
I mentioned earlier
about we were
caring about our
sustained network per core
and our disk IO per core.
So we chose a SKU to match
that and to optimize for that.
And you can see we just about
matched on-premise performance.
And so that tells you
we are well-tuned.
We know what our
on-premise needs are.
And we built hardware
to optimize to that.
Similarly, on n1-standard-4,
it was a little bit better.
But it's pretty much matching
our on-premise speeds,
even though we changed
the SKU slightly.
We didn't bother testing there.
The third line on
the previous slide
was testing without using
GCS as the durable store.
But it didn't really
give us anything.
We do want durability
of our data.
So benchmark findings,
application benchmarks
are critical.
So the MapReduce jobs that
we run have multiple steps--
map shuffle, putting
things on local disk,
moving across the
network, writing
and doing reducer operations,
and then final rights.
So we recommend that
you should always
rely on an application
benchmark like Gridmix,
rather than doing
microbenchmarks,
because microbenchmarks
will give you the maximums,
but they will not give
you what you really need
in terms of sustained compute--
what is it like working
in a real environment.
And it's relatively easy
to capture your load
off some other system.
And in particular
for Google Cloud,
we want to emphasize that
you can treat network
storage like local disk.
And this is really important.
Both cloud storage and
PD offered nearly as much
bandwidth as a direct attached
hard drive on-premise.
So comparing to
plugging in a drive,
network storage equivalent.
And this gives you some
great opportunities.
So it's a big thing that we got.
And that was specific
to Google Cloud.
So we have a few
functional tests from that,
although we find some of the
things that we worked on.
Live migration, which is a
great feature of Google Cloud,
during our Hadoop testing,
we didn't notice this at all.
During other, more
intense testing
in different parts
of Twitter, when
they were doing a
very high request
per second test for
the caches, they
did notice it was
milliseconds of things.
Obviously, we
don't care so much.
In Hadoop we care about
minutes of compute,
and lots of throughput.
We did find some issues with
checksums, which we fixed.
There's a link to
the public JIRA,
where we contributed to that
in collaboration with Google.
And we found a system call
bug on local SSDs which
Google fixed, I, think within
24 hours of us noticing it,
so it was a very quick reaction.
So with that, I want
to hand back over
to Derek, who's going to go over
the evaluation outcomes for us.
DEREK LYON: So I think
my headset's working now.
Great.
So I'd mentioned
that we'd looked
at this across a number of
different workloads, Hadoop
being only one of those.
And there's a lot of
temptation certainly
to get the costs to
work, and the migration
to do a lift-and-shift.
If you're trying to get out of
a data center on a timeline,
that may be an
appropriate decision,
because it leads to
the fastest migration.
And actually, if you're
worried about duplicate cost
during the migration
period, that's beneficial.
In the case of
Twitter, though, when
we actually ran the
analysis, and especially
because we looked at
such a long-time horizon
post-migration, what we
found is that migrating
to an infrastructure that we
hadn't bothered to optimize for
was pretty inefficient.
And it was going to set us
up to then immediately have
to do a second migration
onto something more optimized
pretty quickly, with quite
a bit of time pressure,
because the running
cost of that was
going to be pretty significant.
And of course then we had
risks around the overall cost
and risk and disruption
of that lift-and-shift,
as I mentioned before.
In the case of Hadoop,
it had less dependencies
on the actual production
environment at Twitter.
So it was easier to separate,
which is actually a big deal.
You can draw a nice
line around it,
and move it without having to
move everything all at once.
And especially when
you think about all
the different supporting
systems in the data center,
by the time you actually map
out all those dependencies,
it's actually really attractive
to not have to bring all those,
especially at the beginning.
It was also very helpful
that it was a standard piece
of open-source software.
Other people have already
run it on the cloud.
A lot of the issues
that you might encounter
have already been addressed.
In our case, if we like
or don't like something,
it's easy to change.
And then for the users
on top of our platform,
the particulars of
the infrastructure
are somewhat well
abstracted, because they
think of themselves as just
running on top of Hadoop.
And then where this was
particularly interesting
for us, we see a pretty
big explosion in the ways
that people want to interact
with data, especially
on the ad hoc side.
It used to be that you could
kind of insist that everybody
writes things a certain
way, and there's
a very opinionated stack.
We still believe in that for
the production environment.
But so many
different people that
want to access data in
so many different ways,
especially on the ad hoc side,
that it is very attractive
to be able to put the data
in a storage system that's
separated.
And Google let us do that.
There's also a
long-term bet here,
that Google's already pretty
good in big data machine
learning, other
data-related fields.
And they're investing
a lot there--
more than we can afford
to do, certainly.
And so we're hoping to have
access to that ecosystem.
Certainly, I
actually came to the,
back when this event
was called Live,
and it was 2014 or
something, and it
was the size of this room.
It's come a long
way in five years--
four years, five years.
And if it continued
to grow the same way,
we'd be very excited about that.
So separating compute
and storage for Hadoop,
why was this interesting to us?
It allows us to scale
the different dimensions
independently.
As Dave mentioned, the relative
balance of storage and compute
is pretty different, depending
on our different cluster types.
Especially on the cold side,
it's very storage driven.
On the ad hoc side, the
compute is very, very spiky
and irregular and
hard to predict.
It makes it really easy
for us to separate things
into multiple
different clusters,
and have clusters that
are more built to purpose.
We can mix in Dataproc
in certain situations.
We can run MapReduce
in other situations.
We don't have to
try to figure out
a way to run six different
frameworks on a 10,000 node
cluster without
breaking anything.
So that's attractive.
We also liked the
virtual networking
and project primitives.
This is actually very nice from
an organizational perspective,
where we can have a
coherent set of teams
has a piece of infrastructure
that's assigned to them.
They're wrapped in a
network that doesn't
connect to anything else.
The bill goes
directly back to them.
And we're not thinking about
this as a bill for my team
anymore.
We're thinking
about this as we're
helping them run infrastructure
that's serving their needs,
and they're getting
billed for it directly.
It's also a lot
easier to manage,
because a lot of the state
lives in the object store.
So deployments, there's still
some state in the cluster.
But deploying is a
lot easier than it
would be when you
have to upgrade
thousands and thousands
of nodes in place
without breaking anything.
You can spin up another
cluster next to it.
You can use that for testing.
It's a huge enabler there.
But also for rolling
upgrades and stuff,
it's pretty beneficial.
And it's nice for us to
treat storage as a commodity.
We have a lot of
disks, and I'm actually
very excited about not having
to worry about that quite as
much anymore, although
we will still continue
to have quite a few of them.
I think I hit the
wrong button there.
There we go.
So we're looking at moving
the cold and ad hoc clusters.
I think I mentioned this before.
The production is staying
in the data center.
For the cold cluster, it's
pretty straightforward.
We're going to use
the Cloud storage.
In our case, actually, we
access the data enough,
that we're expecting
most of this
will just be standard storage.
We're not going to
be using the colder
storage tiers too
much, we don't think,
although those may
prove interesting to us
in the future.
This is also an environment
where Dataproc works nicely,
because when we
do run a job here,
it's usually pretty transitory.
And scaling is almost
entirely storage driven.
On the ad hoc side, we're
going to do it a little bit
differently.
We're going to actually
run Twitter Hadoop there.
And here's the stack
that we're going to use.
So we're running on GCE
using our version of Hadoop.
There's a couple of
benefits to this.
One is it minimizes the
amount of difference
between on-premises
and the cloud,
so that when we go
to move jobs, that's
going to be more
straightforward.
We also believe that we can
get better efficiencies there.
We run a pretty, high CPU
and memory utilization
on our clusters, and get
quite a bit of cost advantage
from that.
And we're looking to
preserve that where possible.
We are interested in using
BigQuery and Dataflow
to some extent.
For our scale, we've
had trouble figuring out
a way to get BigQuery to
be cost effective for us.
So we're using that
tactically for use cases
where BigQuery is
particularly well suited.
But we do not have a broad-based
adopt BigQuery for everything
strategy by any means.
So the node config that we
ended up using actually for V1
here is actually
pretty straightforward.
It looks like an n1-standard-8.
We're not planning to
use preemptible VMs
or autoscaling to begin with.
All of these are
interesting things
that I expect that we will
explore in time, however.
So I mentioned that our
production workloads
are staying on-premises.
There's a couple of
reasons for that.
You might ask, if one runs
well, why not the other?
There's a lot more production
dependencies there.
We'd have to pull a lot
more stuff with that.
That's a lot harder
to tease out.
It also increases our
risk if we do that,
because we're building a
pretty large-scale environment.
There's a lot of unique
things that we're going
to do to get this working.
We would love not to
have hardcore production
dependencies on this
infrastructure--
especially in the near-term.
The production environment has
a lot more regular CPU usage.
These are scheduled jobs that
run the same way all the time.
We can build hardware that's
very well suited to that.
We can restrict people
to fewer runtimes,
that are most price performant.
That's all much more reasonable.
But we still think that
we can support that
more efficiently on-premises.
Strategically, what does
this do for Twitter?
It gets us to a
next-generation architecture
for this piece of our stack,
which we're very excited about.
We're going to be able to
leverage capacity and R&D
from Google.
We don't have to carry the
full cost of that ourselves.
We like a model where we're
investing in the things that
are key to us.
But when we have
kind of smaller teams
that want something
that maybe we
can't afford to spin up a full
team of a Google-type scale,
that we have a vendor
solution available there.
We like participating
in a larger ecosystem.
It's nice to be here
with all of you.
We're looking to learn from you,
and get access to more things,
and kind of what we've done
in our data center so far.
We like the idea of having
a strategic collaboration
with Google.
And there's quite
a few other Twitter
teams that are going to do
something with the cloud.
Many of them are much
smaller than we are.
But by having our
team go first, we
basically establish
that relationship,
get everything kind
of going for Twitter,
make it really easy
to move data there,
get it easy to spin
up services there--
all the kind of plumbing
work that needs to happen.
And then the idea is
that many of those teams
can now make a little
bit more localized
decision about whether they
run on the cloud or the data
center, whereas before that was
hard to do in a localized way.
So we get a couple of
benefits from this.
Doing large-scale
ad hoc analysis
and backfills gets
a lot easier when
you can leverage that capacity.
So cold, for example,
doesn't use very much CPU,
until all of a sudden you
have to rewrite everything.
And I'm very excited
for the capacity
problem there to not be mine.
We avoid HDFS elements, like
on the NameNode for example.
We have a copy of our data now
off-site, which is attractive.
Tape backups for us
is not really viable.
So this actually is.
It makes it a lot easier for
people to get at the cold data.
And we're excited to
do more analysis there.
On the platform side,
we have a minority
of workloads that benefit from
some sort of compliance regime.
And that's a little bit
easier to support on Google.
We like the direct
for chargeback
that I mentioned for projects.
Retention management is a little
simpler with some of the tools
that Google provides.
And we're excited
to start exploring
some more of that ecosystem.
So I'm sure a lot of people
here are doing migrations.
You're probably wondering
what a migration
looks like at Twitter.
In some ways, it's
probably similar,
in some ways a little different.
So we have a Google
PSO team that's
on site with us, a
pretty good-sized team.
And they're working with
us on a day-to-day basis,
helping us with the migration.
It's been actually kind
of a nice marriage.
We have a lot of engineers
that know a lot about Twitter,
and the specific software
that we're using.
The Google PSO team knows a lot
about Google's infrastructure,
and so far I think it's
been a nice marriage there.
The network connectivity is
a little different probably
than when other
people are doing.
Given our scale, we needed
to do a PNI with Google.
So we're doing 800 gig
total connectivity.
This is just for Hadoop.
This isn't for
Twitter in general.
This is just for our workloads.
So that's our
network exclusively.
And we're copying that
into a whole bunch
of different buckets.
In most cases, there's a
roughly one-to-one mapping
between a data set and a
bucket for us, which makes
the ACL management very simple.
So we're going have
a lot of buckets.
And it's actually nice that
that's very easy to do.
As I mentioned, we're going
to be splitting ad hoc
and compute.
We're also going to be
doing more smaller clusters
than we do in the data center.
So I think our
largest ad hoc cluster
is something like 6,500
nodes at the moment.
We're going to split that
into three or four clusters
to start with, and then
possibly more later.
We are making
internal teams owners
of these clusters in buckets.
That's a little
bit easier to do,
given the cloud infrastructure.
So when it's a on-premises
infrastructure,
and you're a platform
team that owns it,
the idea of giving
somebody root on a box
that you're administering
is a little terrifying.
There's a lot more that
we can do there that's
more flexibly on the cloud.
IAM has actually taken
a fair bit of work.
We're not doing anything
that complicated.
We're a Google Apps
user, and we use LDAP.
But it's actually
taken quite a bit
of work to figure
out how to do that.
Some of that is because
we're doing secure clusters
as part of this, which
is more complicated
than a typical migration.
And then we're constantly
updating the migration capacity
plans.
We're still pretty
early in that process,
so completion is a ways away.
We have found some limits.
Quite literally,
there's a limits page.
And we find that
we're asking to get
those increased quite a lot.
We found also that
our internal operating
model of 10,000
node clusters is not
something other people seem
to be doing on the cloud.
I don't know how many
other people are doing
that in the data center either.
But we're trying to
adapt somewhat, and run
smaller clusters there.
Per scaling,
scaling up works OK.
Scaling down is a little
bit of an unsolved problem.
So we're not
confident we're going
to achieve a ton of elasticity
in the very near term.
And then we do do some
amount of joint capacity
planning for Google.
I'd say order of
10,000 cores is--
you get some encouragement
to talk to them in advance.
In an order of 10,000
core surprise asks,
you get a lot of encouragement
to talk to them in advance.
So what are we doing now?
We've got the network set up.
We're doing a lot
of work with IAM.
We actually have
dedicated clusters just
for the replication.
Those are set up and running.
We're in the process
of standing up
the clusters, the
proof-of-concept clusters
on the cloud that are going
to be the first instance
of the real cluster.
And then we have a whole
bunch of supporting
management software around
it that we're building out.
We're copying petabytes
of data to the cloud.
Our ongoing copy is going
to be petabytes a day.
Plus there's the 300 that
we have to do up front.
We did have one early use
case that we pulled for.
This has actually
been a pretty fun one.
We had an internal team with
a sort of short-term need
for this use case.
We learned a lot
from this actually.
I'd love to give a
full talk on this
at some point in the future.
So we surprised Google
with a 100,000 core ask.
They met it.
And then we started
hammering GCS with it.
It's been a learning experience.
We have about a 15 petabyte
data set that we're
carrying with Presto there.
And it's taken a little
work, but it's going.
And then we've also been
learning a lot about the cloud
storage connector, and working
with that team very closely.
So I'll give a couple of
recommendations for you,
and then some
conclusions for us.
The recommendations for you
of the tests that we ran,
I would highly encourage you to
do the application benchmarking
and the scale testing.
Some of that seems like it
may have been a bit of a no-op
on Google, right?
It's kind of similar
performance to on-prem.
Do I really need to do this?
We haven't talked about all the
places that we ran these tests.
And mileage does vary depending
on where you run this.
So many of the findings
here are true for Google
in particular, not for
the cloud in general.
And these are the
tests that will
allow you to discover that.
When you compare pricing--
this is actually also kind
of a fundamental one--
there's a temptation to
say I have an 8-core box
with 64 gigs of RAM.
I'm going to go to
the pricing page.
I'm going to see how
much that costs there.
And that's going to be
my price comparison.
The performance characteristics
are different enough
that for any meaningful
workload like this,
that's not a fair
comparison of costs.
And we much prefer--
having done the
application-level
benchmarking-- to compare
the cost of running
a workload on both
environments, and then
allow yourself to architect
it properly, and take
advantage of better or worse
performance as it occurs.
For example, when you do
the 8 cores and 64 gigs
on both sides, you've
completely ignored the network,
which is kind of secretly one
of the most important pieces.
It doesn't show up on your
bill, but it affects your bill
massively.
So make sure that as you're
testing this and querying this,
you're looking at
those types of things.
In terms of
migration planning, I
think you'll get negotiated
into lift-and-shift.
And that may be the
right answer if you're
getting out of a data center.
But in our case, we
benefited a lot from it
did take two years to come
up with exactly what we're
going to do, and
move forward with it.
But I think we have
a much smarter plan
than we would have
otherwise, which
is balancing some short-term
value with speed of execution
and limited risk.
So conclusions that
we drew, some of these
were interesting
findings for us.
If the network is good
enough, locality matters less.
And that's very interesting for
certain categories of workload.
Google's network is pretty good.
So locality doesn't
matter as much there.
When the compute side
of things get stateless,
it's a lot easier to manage.
And being able to
treat PD like local HDD
is very empowering
for a lot of things.
And that one in particular
is not true everywhere.
Cloud adoption is quite complex.
So you can imagine the
service graph at Twitter
is quite complicated,
and it's very difficult
to disentangle that and figure
out exactly what you can move.
That's a big problem.
It takes a lot of thinking.
The architectural
choices themselves
are somewhat non-obvious.
There's various
trade-offs and costs,
and it takes quite
a bit of analysis
to figure out what to do there.
And because of both
of those things,
it's well worth
planning to spend
some time doing the analysis.
And then I think the
concluding thought here is
we're very new to this process.
A lot of you are probably
farther along with Google
than we are.
We're excited to learn
from you at the conference.
So if you're doing something
at similar scale, especially,
and are further along, I would
love to get your business card.
But hopefully we'll
be here next year,
and we will have
actually completed
at least portions
of this migration.
We'll be able to give
some technical talks
on kind of more specific
things that we've done.
And, yeah, we're looking forward
to being part of the community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]